pay attention to who you're going to get
married to try and pick someone that is
emotionally independent that can handle
Life by themselves that can make some
people feel insecure right like I want
someone that's relying on me all the
time and I want them to feel like they
need me that might be a trap for you
find someone that's emotionally
independent find someone that you get
along well with find someone that's calm
someone that's not going to get bent out
of shape about little things and then
just uh have fun you know my wife and I
have fun and I think that's important
some people rely on a partner who is
overly vulnerable overly anxiously
attached as a way to bolster their own
sense of reassurance in a relationship
I've seen this quite a lot I would
recommend you find someone that's more
your equal someone that you're part of a
team with rather than someone that
you're sort of domineering over I
learned this the other day that there's
only one sentence in the Bible about how
you should choose a partner and it says
that you should choose someone that you
could go to war with I like it that's
legit